megan mois que a passé une partie de sa
vie à aider les femmes victimes de
violences ce parc paisible au coeur de
london en ontario est un endroit sacré
pour elle c'est ici qu'on retrouve le
monument des femmes dédié aux victimes
de polytechnique notamment
on rappelle de tout le travail qui reste
à faire explique-t-elle mégane iii que
mène une bataille pour que le terme
féminicide soit défini est inscrit au
code criminel
le but obtenir des données sur les
crimes motivés par la haine contre les
femmes sensibiliser la population et
influencer la manière dont sont menées
les procès et les enquêtes criminelles
amènerait les policiers à investiguer
les crimes contre les femmes sous
l'angle d'un acte et nous
explique-t-elle mégane iii que siège à
la commission des services policiers de
london qui enverra bientôt une lettre au
ministre fédéral de la justice je suis
prêt à écouter des suggestions s'il ya
des lacunes s'il faut combler les
lacunes le gouvernement trudeau se
montre ouvert évalue les possibilités
il ya tout le temps des dvd des options
c'est-à-dire
les options à la détermination la peine
l'idée fait du chemin y compris au
québec est ouvert à ceux effectivement
ça existe des fumistes pensait depuis
longtemps ici au québec est ce qu'il
savait à polytechnique la pandémie il
est confinement ont ramené à l'avant
plan la violence contre les femmes les
chiffres sont éloquents le nombre de
femmes et de filles tuées au canada est
passé de 137 en 2019 à 173 en 2021 oui
définir le féminicide mais la stratégie
doit être encore plus large quoi le bloc
québécois et le npd il faut s'y attaquer
il faut trouver une façon alors
c'est très stadiers au canada
aujourd'hui on est loin d'avoir en place
toutes les ressources nécessaires pour
que les femmes victimes des violences 1
place pour se loger il est temps de
passer à l'action
il faut arrêter de compter les femmes
décédées dit-elle est passé de la parole
aux actes ici louis blouin radio canada
ottawa